hello hi my name is Astrid and I'm
guessing this is the last session of the
day so I'm guessing everybody in the
room is interested in actually being
here so I'm just checking so I'm
actually a security scientist at h2o
briefly just give you a simple
introduction as to what we do you know I
take it to a tutorial as to what were
you what you can do using h2o and one of
the use cases that I'll be working with
is security is kiss but it's a very
basic use case so it's not very
complicated if it is please let me know
and if you are actually interested in
doing things you know while I'm doing
along I can slow down and you know I can
wait for you guys that's not a problem
at all but I'll be showing you the step
by step process so that you clearly know
what to do and how to analyze data using
h2o is that good many questions you're
welcome to ask me questions anytime
through the session that you don't have
to hold it till the end it's it's not a
big thing so don't worry about it
Thanks so I guess we have some of you
coming in okay
so as I said I work as a security
scientist or h2o most of times what I
designers I design algorithms that
detect anomalous behavior networks and
fraud using h2 as a platform and what
what exactly is what exactly is a stock
so you know just an introduction over
h2o we'll be talking about the
architecture the agenda that we'll be
going through as to what we're
presenting today
as I said a simple definition of the
problem I'll also take you through how
you can sell a page so it's it's really
simple but if if some if some people
here haven't tried it even for the first
time then it'll definitely be helpful
then you know through a simple process
of data analysis and looking at the
results so a quick introduction about
h2o we had a company of about 80 people
founded in 2012 we based out of Mountain
View and much of us scientists and
engineers so you kind of get the idea
the composition of a company and the
product itself is open-source hto itself
is a product for machine learning it's
got it's got actual it it's got machine
learning algorithms in it so it's you
can just you know start it off and run
at you don't you don't have to code much
there are interfaces through h2o where
you're not expected to code anything you
know it's just small lock clicking use
but if you're experienced I'm guessing
you know because you guys are here by
data most of you would like to talk to
any application through the Python
interface so I'm guessing you guys are
like of my experience and you know a
first time user would be interested in
using h2o so the platform is distributed
parallel and in memory which makes it
really fast and scalable so this is a
general Vo for executors team so trouble
hasty to be Shivani and Steven white are
the three advisors of a company they
took Shaunie and hasty have been
statisticians at Stanford and Stephen
boy is actually you know I'm Sophie
electrical engineering at Stanford as
well so they've been helpful in you know
in designing our algorithms on platform
so as I said what is H so it's basically
a machine learning analytical platform
we've got linear models we've got random
for us and you've got gradient boosting
machines we've also got pcs for
unsupervised approaches we've also made
it easy by having api's for different
languages we have api's for R we have e
Oh should I say that just just we have
AP has for fightin and R and of course
you can talk to it through Java Scala
the you can actually talk to through
excel and tableau as well which I will
claim that I don't know how to do it so
if you have questions for that please do
email me I will take it to the right
person and I'll help you guys out with
it so I want to fuse that we can handle
a big amounts of data big data coming
from you know from the disk or from HDFS
or if you have lot effects stored in
some kind of memory so it's it's easy
for us to handle so of course you know
the machine learning space is divided
into two parts supervised and the am
supervised in the supervised space we
support GLM's
naive Bayes which are I mean is
artistical here
classic statistical approaches we have
ensembles which is random forests and
the G VMs we also have deep learning I
believe Fabrizio should be in the
audience here Hey so he will be
showcasing a really cool deep water
presentation on Sunday you guys should
not miss it because it's it's it's part
breaking you know development and deep
learning and deep learning is
approaching at h2o so you guys should
not miss that in the unsupervised space
we have k-means clustering PCA and
auto-encoders which we you know they use
on a daily basis for our
so what's what's the workflow how does
h2 actually work so h2 itself is a
simple JVM you know which you can run on
your system itself or you can run it
through Hadoop and spark and you can get
the data in through HDFS you know disk
native disk formats and s3 sequel and no
sequel you can use spark and Hadoop to
run h2o things run in parallel you know
in memory as I told you earlier and you
can interact from the multiple sets of
languages and applications through h2 or
together each so also has its own native
interactive format which is called flow
it's actually a web interface which is
kind of really easy if you're starting
off it's it's a simple point-and-click
interface that helps you quickly learn
how h2o works how to play around with it
and as you progress you know you can
talk through the dress API to everyday
show so as we are here PI data in a very
simple way this is how you actually pull
in data into h2 well it's as simple as
you know this is your import file and
you can get in your file and so this is
a general architecture of h2o works we
have the h2o cluster where you have
multiple servers you know built as a
cluster then you have you you have a
source of the data so using the pythons
using Python as a language we talked to
this cluster using the REST API so using
the REST API the data gets called into
the cluster now the data gets read in
parallel in into the cluster and it is
it actually exists as a distributed data
frame in the cluster and in Python so
you can actually see the data frame as a
panda's data object it's very similar to
find us lis the object I don't want to
say it's it's the actual thing very
similar to it but here in essence it's
actually a pointer to the data frame
that exists on the cluster so if you
were to disconnect yourself from the
cluster and try and see what this object
there would be nothing out there it'd
just be an empty binder the same thing
in our as well we have primarily focused
on getting the data to be on the cluster
just so that you know the the the core
is optimized to run faster instead of
you know moving things from your local
machine to the cluster so in this
diagram it's basically the same thing
but what we would like to highlight is
that you can access the data from your
HDFS as well you can read in the data it
from HDFS and you know because HDFS
itself is sold on multiple clusters you
can have your data right in parallel
which makes it even more faster into the
h0 plus stuff so so today's agenda you
know we kind of had a fair idea of what
the architecture is we use the h2o
Python API to work with the problem and
a simple in our data analysis we also
look at what kind of a model we did and
we look at how how we can interpret the
results so the problem that we'll be
working today is is one of my most
favorite problems I've ever worked on
for probably about nine years now it's
basically trying to analyze and
correlate security events across an
enterprise organization so I'll just
give you a quick example of what happens
so you have Network Devices you have
system devices and you have endpoints
now all these devices actually are
creating logs and they're sending out
information to one central logging
machine now all these logs tends to get
accumulated or aggregated at that point
now if you're a security analyst you
want to be able to identify what event
is happening in sequence to what event
that all be happened so you want to be
able to correlate you know create a time
a time series analysis of these events
so that you want to find out if
something bad happened you know if
somebody got attacked or if a sequence
of events happen that led to an attack
you want to be able to immediately
identify it and that is something that
actually people here at Capital One have
so here I'll be showing you a very
simple version of it it's not at all
complicated it's very simple and what
we're gonna try and do is so basically
all these logs get aggregated but before
you get to a point where you can analyze
these correlational events you want to
find out where these logs are coming
from because practically what happens is
when you have hundreds of hunting the
different sources of logs you don't know
where these logs are coming from there
are multiple machines of the same kind
you know sending the same kind of blogs
so it becomes a problem
so in today's problem what we will do is
we will identify the logs will identify
the sources of their logs and using
machine learning we will try and predict
the source of the logs based on what
information we get in those logs so so
that's that's the basic premise of what
we are going to do today any questions
up till now before we go ahead anything
at all any questions about H so what
we're gonna do it is it is a hands-on
yeah I was just so yes so you're
actually doing machine learning
primarily because there are lots of log
sources that you do not know where
they're coming from so you're like okay
you know let's go probabilistic we don't
need to be deterministic in this because
much of the logs have very similar
behavior so you're going very
probabilistic because you know there's a
very good chance of being accurate ok so
so what we well I'll show you is can you
guys see the data or is that is that a
bit difficult for anyone the people in
the back okay thanks okay so what we
have here is is the sample data this is
actually a sample of the logs itself
here we have logs from three different
actually sorry yeah three different
machines that have come in we have you
know from the DHCP which is basically
your domain servers and you have the
sorry your VMware server so three
different kinds of servers so now you
want to be able to classify them in
their own you know in their own bins so
we start looking at this data and what
we find is they all have something
really interesting you know at the top
right corner if you see on the left hand
corner of all these logs they have a
number enclosed and you know and the
greater than or less than sign that
seems to be very peculiar the the next
thing is you see that the dates actually
kind of interesting as well you know the
dates are not the same all across so the
dates could be used as one way of
identifying what these logs are and you
also have the process you know in the
first log line you have DHCP deal in the
second log line you have VP XA which I
have actually highlighted um again I'm
hoping to the people in the back can see
it clearly and you also have things like
you have IP addresses and your MAC
addresses in these as well so these are
so if you go ahead a bit these are a
fair good set of you know features that
we can think of so you can look at you
know these IP addresses these different
types of date formats where the log the
the number that you saw in the left hand
side which is actually called the
priority level the priority level is an
identifier that the system tells you
that what priority you're supposed to
read this lot is it really important is
it you know is the house burning down or
is everything okay so it's
is that kind of an indicator and that's
that's very important when you're
reading blogs and you one thing that we
also see is these logs tend to have a
certain length you know number of
characters logs coming from the same
sources kind of looks similar at least
in terms of the number of you know
characters it has and if you observe a
bit more carefully maybe not in this
case but if you look at a lot number of
logs you would probably see that the
words that are there in certain you know
logs that are common are actually the
same thing so you have seen similar
kinds of words in logs that come from
the same source
so using that let's go ahead and you
know we think of these as a first set of
features so as I said the priority value
which is the number on the left hand
side the date format the date format
will actually classify it as five
different date formats here what what
you can see in the in the sample log is
actually two different kinds but what we
have identified in the data itself is
five different so we will keep that
there and the number of characters who
is going to be another feature number of
IP addresses is another one number of
MAC addresses and finally we also look
at what is the fraction of the words
that exist in the Lord okay
of different sizes of characters well
the if you have a word of four letters
okay out of how many different are of
how many different words does this I
mean how many words actually make up you
know four different four character
letter words is is something that we
look up so let me take you to
okay so okay before this have you is
everyone here ready with h2o or the
package I would love to go go that with
you guys if someone wants to try it out
anybody here interested in trying it out
you know how to get at the start okay so
we have people okay so let me take you
down to them so let me put that link up
so the link you'll actually so the link
you'll actually have to go to is h2o AI
slash download
and you'd see on your left hand side you
will see h2o and just click on that so
you can download the latest table so
that you know you don't want any
surprises and you'll get another page
where you will get a zip file if I'm
going fast please just raise your hand
and stop me that's perfectly okay or if
I'm going too slow raise your hand and
say that as well oh is that is that
gonna take a while for you whoa oh okay
she should have got the head of the line
man
okay maybe anybody's got spare USB keys
in case we can probably do that but
maybe not share it I think that would be
a sad thing okay so let's assume you've
got the Downloads head so next what you
need to do is you need to install the
Python API
you know the Python package that you
need for h2o if someone's actually in
the process of downloading and would
want me to slow down please let me know
like right now okay okay
do you know what's the estimate that
you've got oh okay
we've got five minutes okay okay keep
going okay up I don't you right now yeah
because that's what I'm set up for I
otherwise I could've done the end so now
if you want to install another PI the
Python package as well so can you so you
know you can do the pip install request
tablet and scikit-learn now you can also
install saying pip install h2o you don't
necessarily have to go to this link but
if you can get to that link and use that
specific package it'll be great
is it okay I said yeah I didn't take
that myself okay oh is it okay thank you
yeah
so the view file is in in the zip itself
so it should be ready oh yeah so right
now it's 2.7 is what you're supporting
yes yes myself apart is balance
anybody successfully downloaded it yeah
no that would just give you the Python
package yes yeah
okay okay are you are you are can you
lick it off to another network or
something which supports it I'm guessing
it might be the load to a Amazon from
here it's what I would believe so I
think we probably should have hosted it
locally might have been easier anyone
still trying to download it trying to
install Python package or JVM I mean a
sorry Adi jar Oh took a long time okay
okay cool so now let's assume that this
thing is there on your computer which
fortunately it's not the case but
and and after you've got the hto package
all you have to do is just unzip it and
you this is what comes up so you have
your Python package I think you've
mentioned that it actually comes with it
so that's a good thing and you have the
h2o jar and the are landry as well and
the packages so um to run this all you
got to do is you have to run it this way
let me just you say okay can you see it
now okay
I think I might have session coming let
me just check
let me try this again so if you can see
you literally have to run just Java - JA
in a storage jar to get the package up
and running and that that starts running
this server so now you can I tend to
forget my IP address I'm just copying
that okay some and then you'd have to
get onto your ipython notebook or I
think Jupiter notebook is what it's
called now so just one that and if you
if you have a session running on your
Jupiter notebook that'll be great
anyone have any trouble with the
notebooks even oh yeah oh okay
so you I you can actually download the
Hangout let's pull that up
Google is there for everything
oh the one I've made it up okay I can
share that you after the session if
that's okay
is that fine okay so I mean I I don't
mind going slow for you to actually type
things out that's something that you're
interested in okay so yeah you call in
the you know the h2o library let's hope
advance yeah that's good so from the hto
library we also call the the GBM
estimator because that is what we'll be
using to classify our logs today and the
way you connect to the server is it show
dot in it which where you provide the IP
address the port number
and it's always good to use strict
version check equals false primarily
because we tend to do releases every two
weeks we and if you know you are an
enterprise and you tend to move a lot
more slow than two weeks which I'm sure
you do you don't want to be you know
committing yourself to the latest
versions and this the single fail every
time so if you set this to false it will
it'll work fine but you know you you
won't have some features but if there's
a big feature we will actually let you
know and you will be expected to move to
the next version so just remember you
got to do that just so that it's easy
for you for your daily daily working and
once you connect you actually get some
basic cluster information you know as to
what what's the amount of memory how
long your systems been up who's logging
in and stuff like that now it's exactly
the same way when your cluster when you
connect to a remote cluster as well
there is no difference in how you
connect to a remote cluster it's
basically the same thing right in this
case what I'm doing is I'm running the
server on my local machine and I'm
connecting to that and it's working fine
it's the same way how when you connected
remote server now there is a there are
situations where you know you have LDAP
access or you need to provide passwords
to get onto those clusters at that time
there are actually parameters you can
provide in this call itself which will
help you you know access things through
LDAP or using a password and our
username so you can do that as well I
know I believe there'll be like one kind
of a main ODI master Nadia that you need
to connect to so like I kind of jumped a
step let me just take you back to my
slides
so after we've got after we've got these
features now so you can just take some
time if someone is still setting it up
just use this time to set it up I'll
just run through some basics of what the
data are parts of the data so after
we've got these features now the next
thing that we need to do is we need to
be you know labeling the data because
right now we don't know what these logs
are where these logs are from now
primarily because this is a supervised
learning approach as well so what I did
is I went ahead and actually label the
data because I knew what each of these
log sources are from so the way we label
it is something like this so if you look
at it on the left hand side is a text
token that is unique to a certain kind
of a log I know the right hand side is
actually a label so if you see the first
token which is luck which says RS a dot
IMS dot
n is actually from you know the RSA
SecurID systems okay and a sa is very
clearly from Cisco a SI devices and
something which is you know ACC with two
brackets is actually from the big IP
network and so on so so basically what
we did this V Talks unique specific
tokens from logs and we actually
identify them as to what their sources
and we label this data
now the reason I'm repeating this again
the reason we did this is because this
is a supervised approach and we need
these labels to be there so that the
mission so the algorithm can actually
learn what kind of log comes from what
kind of source and that is why we went
ahead and we did this yeah
we avoid as much as possible to not have
wild card we want it to be unique enough
but but not have wild cards in them yeah
so the purse so if you see the percent
is actually escaped so that means it's
actually it's it's taken as this yeah oh
good question yeah so I didn't change
that I should have changed it but
initially we were having so many
different logs we actually had to create
separate text files for each of them and
the code the initial set of code that I
wrote for this was processing this data
separately you know and piping them
separately and putting it into a
separate text file so which is why it
remained the same way but yeah good
catch nice so after we've labeled the
data and you know we have identified
these these features then we basically
get the data in shape so that we can
push it through the model and this is
how it looks like so what you see here
is the data that we'll be sending in to
the h2 algorithm so in let me try and
explain the first one for you the 30 is
actually the priority value that comes
from the data the five is the date
format that existed in that specific lot
138 uh by the way before I go ahead can
you guys see from the back numbers and
everything is okay okay
the 138 is say here
this is a sample yes this is a sample
the total number the total number of log
files that I was working with this about
plus of 135 so no it's actually a factor
in the Lord so across the log which is
like you know Allah but so many
characters long that is a unique talk to
token to identify that this is a
security log and by the way just for
information this is how current a
security analyst identify logs they
don't have an algorithm which you know
which uses machine learning to do it so
if you're using Splunk in your
enterprise environment they actually use
these kind of tokens they they have
people who write these tokens on a daily
basis and who update this on to Splunk
servers across the world to catch these
logs so that's what they do
so the data gets formatted into this
format which is so 30 is basically the
priority value 5 is the date format 138
is the number of characters 2 is the
number of IP addresses and that logs 0
is the number of MAC addresses analog
network ID is the actual label which is
the response in this case and following
which you have words that are from four
characters long to 15 characters long so
basically what it's telling is the
fraction so in in the first case you see
0.4 0.2 0.2 and then you know a 0 and
then 0.2 it's basically telling you that
there are four character that 40% of the
words in this log are actually four
characters long and 20% of five and six
and eight characters long there is
nothing which is seven characters long
so it's it's basically measuring the
number of characters in each of these
words and all the words that we actually
measure must be available in a
dictionary so we don't take random you
know character strings which are four
characters long of I characters long
they must actually exist in a dictionary
that's what we try it's it's the same
thing with the next log line as well you
know you see the priority value is 1 6
is 6 and so on so any questions up till
here yes
yes yeah sorry yeah they must exist an
English boy yeah okay so um so now that
we've got you know view format data
that's ready to go through the h2
algorithm what we do now is we take that
data so what do you see down is we're
entering the path where the data exists
and let's run it and so that has been
processed
now we import that data into h2o okay
that was quite quick the next step that
we also do is we define what these
columns are now this is important to
know because when you're analyzing so
many different fields which people
normally tend to do in a machine
learning using a machine learning
platforms it's good to know you know
what are you learning
so so h2o dot in it there is also H dot
connect but if it's if you're using a
cluster oh yeah okay let me show you
that
so it's Java space - ja h to order me
Josh
so um okay good thing that we're
actually here so here you can you can
use this when you're running the Java or
the h2o jar file you can actually use
the output of this as a debugging you
know process so let's say something goes
wrong through your REST API call when
you're using Scala or Java or something
everything gets actually logged in this
interface so you know you can you can
scroll through this and see if there is
any trouble
you can figure out how things are
working if things have failed if things
are crashing this will actually tell you
so this is a really good place this is a
rich source of data for you to keep an
eye on when you're using h2o
so coming back here will actually define
all the columns that we have and you
know just get a fair idea of what the
columns are again so the next thing what
we do is in the process of machine
learning you actually have to divide the
data into you know training and testing
or training and validation now the
training part is where the machine
learns or the algorithm in this case
learns what the data looks like or what
the data is in terms of its inputs and
its response so it's if you were to be
looking at linear algebra you know you
give it a bunch of problems which is X
plus y equals you know 10 or 2x plus 2y
you know equals let's say 40 so it it
that's how it's supposed to learn sorry
20 not funny and that's all so when you
given these kind of algorithms that's
what that's how it learns what those
values could be and that's the part of
the training that actually happens so
here what we're doing is here we're
taking 80% of our data and so we're
taking our entire dataset and dividing
80% dividing it into 80 and 20% the 80%
actually goes as a part of training and
then we use the knowledge that we have
learned from the 80% to predict on the
remaining 20%
the next thing that we have to do is
after you've defined what part of our
data actually becomes a prediction and
what part of data is the training we
also have to define what are the input
variables and what is the response
variables and that is what you define
here so if you look at it what we define
in our Y is basically the log class what
class does this log belong to and the
rest of the rest of the data actually
goes on as inputs and as I said earlier
we were using a we're using gbmh so GBM
model to to classify this and this is
this is a you know multi-class problem
that we are having yeah
is the notebook no it's actually not
possible yet much easy okay yes I think
I must pass here my bad sorry do you
have a location where you can post it I
can give you the
yellow to send them the data oh you did
yeah I love to clean up so here we're
actually defining the the model that
we're using be using the GBM here and
you know you can you can define the
model and one of the things that you can
also have is you can you can score each
I oppression you you might want to see
how each hydration scores and you want
to see the result of each hydration in
our case we're actually setting it to
false because we it kind of takes a lot
of time so which is why we're not doing
it but you could do it and it will give
you results and you can find out how
good each hydration how your write
iterations are progressing what we will
do is we'll just look at the final
results of each of these alterations we
also defined a number of trees how many
trees are going to be used for for
creating this module and the learning
rate so the learning rate actually tells
the model at what rate does it learn
from the data so that's that's the
information it provides and one thing
that we are also using here is we are
using something called cross polls
basically meaning that if your data so
let's say you have you know one big
chunk of data the training data set is
actually divided into five different
blocks it's divided into five different
blocks and each time you train the data
is trained on four blocks and it's
predicted on one more block so basically
the idea here is cross polls actually
prevent actually limit overfitting so
because your training on a set of data
that that is not seen by the training
itself the overfitting in data actually
is minimized by using cross form and
that's what we do by selling the enfolds
here yeah so that's in addition this is
in addition to that
so the next thing that we'll use will
actually run the model so this and this
takes quite a bit of time so you're
welcome to ask any questions in the
house if you want to catch up to this
whiner and really sorry I think I should
have posted the notebook earlier than
this
I probably do that right after in case
anyone is still interested in what here
yeah oh so in this case the depth is
about V we are at about 24 I'm not sure
what that may be
let's Fabricio do you I think you should
be able to pass a sparse matrix and so J
GBM I believe so
yeah so it's gonna take quite some time
so you can use this time for any
questions or anything at all yeah so the
data set we have right now is about
700,000 records when you say feature
selection you mean like create a feature
now so h2o is only able to pick up
feature so you have to define the kind
of features that you want so every data
munging process that I saw um before I
came to the ipython notebook I took you
through a process of how you get to a
point in point where you've got the data
ready for the h2o to load up till then
it's you know it's kind of outside h2o
so you'll have to define the features
that you want and then you'll have to
come in to h2o so which you know that
that's more of domain science than
machine learning itself so we can run on
Apache spark so we have something called
a sparkling water which runs on spark no
we yeah it sure does not require spot we
can understand along
yeah this is yeah this is a sparkling
water talk I mean talk tomorrow
so by McHale from each you as well so
now so because we are completely in
memory the moment you get your data into
h2o cluster it really doesn't matter how
you get things up but if if your output
of the analysis is pretty large I think
that's when you will have to think of
how you're going to move the data out so
we can write back to HDFS we can write
back to native disk as well so it's
completely and if you're using like
let's say spark you can write the object
the way you know you write a native
spark data frame column so you can do
that as well
no so if if you have it available to the
h2o cluster so if if if it's visible to
the issue or cluster we can read it in
parallel so the multi so let's say
you're talking to our environment and
you can actually read it in parallel
into the cluster
yeah justa yes yeah yeah we can read
from asturias valia
the flow okay I can do that
so this is the issue of flow interface
which I was telling you earlier about
this is one of the most easiest ways to
get started relates to well let's say
you want to work on the same problem you
know using flow and you don't have a
Python API you can you know import the
file from here and can say
I'm saying
oh thanks
so this is of you would import the data
and then you pass it so it shows capable
of United in to Fang what's yours
feed separator and things like that then
you can set how you want each of these
fields so in in our case this would be
you know a factor or an enumerated but
the the priority value would actually be
an enumeration so you'll have that set
as enum and same will be with the same
Olivia today the date and yeah the
length of the carrot the number of
characters will actually be numeric your
number of IP address will again be
numeric and in a number of MAC addresses
will be numeric everything else will
actually be noumic so you just have to
change this one field which is actually
an in anyway and then you pass the data
it's pretty quick and then here you
actually get to the fields itself so
here you can say you know how you want
to split you can say you want to split
it by 7525 or like the way we did it
there you know split by 8020 and then
you can fund this so now you want to
train this data so you choose the Train
the data set that you want to Train and
then you'd say build a model and it
would be a GBM your training frame would
be sorry validation repeated 20 percent
your training will be the 80 percent
your foals would be set to 5 and in this
case your response column would be set
to c6
if I'm right yeah
and then you know you can set your
parameters that go into your GBM which
is 50 trees we have set a depth and
minimum number of zeros so minimum
number of roses you know you want to set
for the amount of training that you want
to do like if you are okay with you know
to those having a certain value and you
want to use that training then you can
set that to true or if sorry - but if
you want like five you can set that out
and you can see their learning rate you
can check whether you wanna score in
each iteration because you want to study
the output of each iteration and so then
all you do is you just go ahead and say
build model so it basically does the
same thing that's how it's happening
right now but this is just a very easy
interface of working with Asia oh I'm
sorry yes we should have an air like you
know the standard Airlines data set we
should have it on our website let me
just follow
see I'm guessing you can't see the link
hang on let me just
you see the link is that
the yeah
yes so we don't have so it's not per
unit of computation it's just like how
you would rent out you know an AWS
server I
there must be an ami that we that we
actually deploy with h2o in it so that
that should make it easy for you if you
wanted to you know use the am i yeah we
don't have a cluster offer on that step
on there now
it's basically to build a model yeah
yes yeah and then that that's how I'm
running right now so I'm running the h2o
and my localhost
Oh
yes
so so you're saying opening a present
about me there is this a flight quickly
say in your master and that you set up
your own buffer so that they are they
show clusters so when you've won in your
cluster the default behavior this will
join you if you're with me
why
silly yeah so the appendages to be
impotent because I've mounted DNA is
actually the Buffs incomes of
occupations baby you know it summer
because well together so this is
actually
yes please say that's true if they were
just curious
yeah so the only problem right now is
I've seen the screen on 1920 by 1080 so
I know exactly where it ends but this is
the code 768 sorry exactly but it should
be soon
oh um actually yeah I can probably show
you another
so he so here to you actually you can
see the the tree number that's actually
being built so this gives you a fair
idea as well as to where we are right
now I believe you're probably somewhere
near the 40th I'm not sure so I don't
want I want to say something wrong here
yeah and so I mean not me but there are
other people who have actually done well
with that I'm I usually just eat with
random forests in deep learning in GBM
sir
so can you say that out loud yeah so
that could be each Surratt in it
can you yeah so the H stroller connect
function is actually the new function
that we have if you're connecting to a
cluster so which is why you'll see both
of it but if you connected it'll
actually let you know that you're
connected to the self
Oh
sure we close so um actually let that
keep running I mean I have models from
the previous iteration that have already
done I can probably take you through
that or I should have done that earlier
uh-huh
so what do you see here is basically the
model output that we have and this gives
you all the information about the number
of you know trees that will Ram that we
use for this case and the size of the
data that we used the minimum depth of
the trees the max depth and the number
of leaves that we use for the entire
analysis and this one that you actually
see is the training part of the model
this is also the cross-validation I mean
C is a confusion matrix for the training
part of the validation that we see so
what we see here is that how much of you
know error exists in in how we have done
in terms of classification as you can
see so you can see some of them pretty
decent but some of them are pretty bad I
mean I would consider this to be pretty
bad so one of the reasons some you know
some some of them don't get classified
really well is because of the limited
data or how very the features are across
the difference across the logs so that
tends to be a problem but otherwise it's
fairly ok this is our training and here
you also see as to how things go across
through your multiple iterations so you
see that you know the scoring is
actually increasing it's getting your
better iteration as we go along I mean
we're getting a better result as we go
along and this is actually our
validation matrix and here you see you
should see big errors so you so you know
this one shows about 60% you know
wrongly classified this is one of one
which is a big problem I believe so
so you know as there is limited amount
of data there's not enough data for the
mission for the algorithm to actually
learn how these Lots exists so that's
one of the problems that we also see the
the third one that you would see is you
see how it performs under cross
validation so here - you see you know
fair amount of breakdown in terms of
errors so here you see one is about 22%
and this one is about that one
so you see a fairly bit of errors if you
if we have enough data things tend to be
really good things tend to get
classified really well but some of the
problems in log itself this is kind of a
real-world issue with logs is that some
devices don't have so many log records
compared to the other some of the
machines so this is an existing problem
that we have so that's going to be there
all the time
so what we see here is that you know we
see about close to about 99 but that's
not exactly true I mean we all know that
because you know some of them because
it's a multi-class problem some of them
are completely classified wrongly so you
have to take this number with probably a
spoon of salt and so yeah it gives you
how pure all your cross falls actually
were and how well they were sorry so I
did someone have a question okay
he also gets coding history so this
basically gives you a lot of information
about how your model ran you also can
get your variable importance so you see
that priority ID tends to be very good
at identifying these slots because
priority IDs actually tell you where
these logs are coming from and what
they're saying the date format is a
strong identifier as well the IP
addresses are a strong identifier but
you know MAC addresses which we thought
could be is not necessarily that
important then the world ratios are the
next set of important next set of things
that are actually pretty good so you can
look at the variable importance as well
and you know you basically can get the
same numbers out here and if you want to
look at the confusion matrix separately
you can do that as well so the one thing
that you can actually do is visualize
this using your h2o flow and let me
quickly show you that so here you see
how you model as I treated and you know
has I try to really reduce its log loss
so it's gone through you know multiplied
iterations and it's become better as you
go along and you can visualize your
variable importance as well and the same
thing that we actually saw through your
Python interface is visibly available
here and you can see across our
confusion matrix as well here so you
know if you want to look at the errors
it's usually on the right hand side so
and this comes for your training your
validation and your cross-validation
you can also production like this code
if you would like to so we have a pose
already for that purchase a plain old
Java object which is literally a Java
code all you have to do is if you are
running this standalone compile this
Java code and start running it on any
server that you want literally that's it
there's nothing else to it if you want
to put it you know
into another piece of code that you
already have like let's say you want to
put it into storm then you literally run
do a call on this using storm library
and you you're ready to go so this part
of it makes it really easy to implement
an algorithm that you don't need any
translations to go from your model
building to production Eliza get it's
really easy to move from model building
to oxidizing it because you literally
have to take this pose you and apply it
so yeah so that's the slide I mean sorry
that's a presentation any questions up
to now anything at all
yeah
no that's steam steam steam yeah sistema
steam is the orchestration tool
sparkling water is where H 2 runs on
spark um I actually am NOT I don't know
how I hat is why I had an orchestration
tool as well okay
okay um I actually don't have that
information I'm sorry so let me if you
like I can fully like email you back
about this interesting okay any of the
questions okay thank you